Chris Pratt wants you to be a dad David
pista fanboys you you have locked into a
serious love fest I never know this
stuff but it's always fun to find it out
I mean it's always fun to find it out
period James Gunn this is his baby this
is he creates this he knows what he
wants he's completely on top of it he's
got all the layers that are fun and he's
created an incredibly dense movie I
thought he did a spectacular job with
balancing all the relationships and
growing all the relationships the
relationship between Peter and his
father was really important and I
thought it was handled extremely well by
him in terms of what's relatable
does anybody have any tape out there I
would have put some tape over that that
funny nobody has anything not a single
person has take you have an atomic bomb
in your bag if anybody's good at it for
you - I know that I'm Jonathan Schwartz
one of the producers said that you were
very into exploring the mythology of the
world looks helpful when you're doing
that to go back to the comics with it
talking with James talking to James my
job is to try to create entertaining
ways of telling the story James one
wants to tell through a character
because my character and what his
involvement is but in order to do that I
need to know what James wants from that
character and what he doesn't want from
that character for me that's what I feed
off of to be able to sort of try to take
a character that has almost no
perimeters as I never played a character
that has no parameters I did you've
created your own existence and you go to
earth and you've decided that I'm going
to look like Kurt Russell that's what
I'm gonna do
it's like that's a strange choice okay
[Applause]
[Music]
after all these years I've found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter